c'est une étape supplémentaire vers la
fermeté de la part du gouvernement de
hong kong ce lundi l'exécutif du
territoire semi autonome a exigé des
écoles qu'elle retire les livres
susceptibles de violer la loi sur la
sécurité nationale adoptée par pékin le
30 juin dernier en guise de protestation
contre ce retrait des feuilles blanches
ont été brandis par des militants
opposés au gouvernement central chinois
car ilham la chef de l'exécutif de hong
kong a de nouveau réaffirmé que son
gouvernement appliquera vigoureusement
la nouvelle loi et met en garde les
militants radicaux
le gouvernement de hong kong va
appliquer vigoureusement cette loi et je
mets en garde ces radicaux de ne pas
tenter de violer cette loi ou de
franchir la ligne rouge
car les conséquences d'une violation de
cette loi sont très graves sur twitter
my pompéo s'est emparé de cette décision
le chef de la diplomatie américaine
estime que cette disposition est un acte
de censure
l'encré à peine sèche de la draconiennes
loi sur la sécurité nationale des
autorités de hong kong retire maintenant
les livres des bibliothèques interdisent
les slogans politiques et impose la
censure dans les écoles les etats unis
condamnent ces attaques orwellienne
contre les droits et les libertés du
peuple d'hong kong
cette nouvelle loi vise notamment à
punir la subversion la sécession le
terrorisme et la collusion avec les
forces étrangères
au total 27 pays dont la france le
royaume uni et le japon accuse la chine
de vouloir museler l'opposition
hongkongaise
le congrès américain a adopté jeudi une
loi qui prévoit de sanctionner les
responsables chinois appliquant ces
nouvelles règles mais la loi devra
encore être promulgué par le président
donald trump pour entrer en vigueur